Welcome back everyone it's Charlie we have
a brand new Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania
scene to break down of Kang and his time
travel ship there's a bunch of cool Easter
eggs and connections to the Fantastic Four even
to Dr Doom so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos in the new scene they release
we get a way better high-res nice shiny look at
Kang's time travel ship and his armor it looks
just like the comic book version I love the way
they did his suit he's got a bunch of different
types of Technology here in the quantum Realm
of the trailer that serve different purposes
the giant City it's based on the comic book
version of chronopolis the city that he rules
over in the distant future which they also uses
inspiration for the TBA but I think that's going
to wind up being a different variant of Kang so
like each has their own different spin on a lot
of the comic book Easter eggs but in the MCU in
this movie this King the Conqueror variant uses
this place not just as a regular City to house
his army or as a giant Fortress it's also meant
to be a giant device that he uses to control the
entire Multiverse like his master plan for using
the quantum realm to win the Kang Multiverse War
the actual giant golden chair that is sitting in
here looks really comfy like there's actually a
seat behind him here too like the seat that he
sits in and then another passenger seat behind him
you have to picture a variant of ravana rensslayer
sitting back there with him this chair is his
actual personal time travel ship that he uses
to jump around to different timelines like the
actual ship itself it's based on a couple of his
time travel ships in the comics most notably his
original time travel ship from the Fantastic Four
number 19 back in 1963. there's a couple separate
Easter eggs here in connections to the Fantastic
Four in Doctor Doom the other big connection to
the Fantastic Four you'll notice in the trailer
he's wielding the blue-colored quantum energy it
even seems like he's integrated into his biology
like his eyes glow blue when he takes his mask
off he gives it off in Blast shooting Ant-Man
trying to kill him it's the same type of blue
colored Quantum energy that Mr Fantastic used
in Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness in the 838
Universe I don't think that means that this King
the conquer variant came from the a E3 universe
but that would be another cool connection if he
was this variant of Kang the Conqueror isn't
meant to be the 616 MCU version either so he
is from Another Universe the version of Kang that
came from the regular MCU universe's future was
that he who remains variant of Kang he's the
person who won the Kang Multiverse War because
Kevin feige the Marvel producer said that the
sacred timeline that he had been ruling over for
all of time covered pretty much everything that
we'd seen in all the Marvel movies and TV shows
up to that point everything that had happened on
screen had happened inside the sacred timeline
so still big question which Universe this King the
Conqueror variant the more evil one came from Kang
is also meant to be a descendant of Reid Richard's
many thousands of years removed his original name
was Nathaniel Richards we got a little bit of his
backstory from the he who remains variant of King
all of them have very similar backstories with
subtle differences that lead them to different
ends like some of them wind up being way more evil
than the others as he teased during the episode
episode and if you think I'm evil just wait till
you meet bye variants you came to kill the devil
right well guess what I keep you safe going from
the Fantastic Four cane connection because of them
using similar types of energy they also based Mr
Fantastic's Quantum energy here on Doctor Doom's
time travel platform in the comics this is Michael
Waldron the writer and Sam Raimi the director
talking about that well shot a latch was pleasure
to work with Reed Richards of the Fantastic Four
so is John hello Stephen teleportation device he
uses to get into the scene is something we took
from the comics that's Doctor Doom's uh Doctor
Doom's uh time door time platform Stephen but
it's not the Scarlet Witch that we fear and
while it is not Professor X's first time on
screen it is the first time we see that uh over
chair from the Animated Series Pete Richards is
my favorite Marvel Comics character so it was a
real honor to write his first entry I guess here
in the museum I don't know if they ever planned
on Doctor Doom actually being in the movie that
would have been really cool but there was meant
to be a version who existed in the 838 universe
and that's how Mr Fantastic came up with some of
the ideas of how to use quantum energy this way so
you just have a lot of people using the same type
of quantum energy in the same way originally when
Kang discovered time travel in alternate universes
the Multiverse he was just a regular scientist
and historian just a regular guy living in the
distant future one day he winds up discovering
plans for Doctor Doom's time travel platform form
which to him had been built thousands of years
ago way more primitive so he takes Doctor Doom's
plans for his timeship upgrades everything with
Hypertech like the future Tech he has access
to tests it with his first mission being to
go back to ancient Egypt pretending to be the
Rama Tut version of his character they actually
had Rama Tut Easter eggs during the moon night
episodes and I believe there are going to be
some Rama Tut Easter eggs in the Loki season 2
trailer I've already done a video about that so
I'll link it at the end of this and down in the
description below there were also some Rama Tut
Easter eggs during the end of Loki season 1 as
well like he had a bunch of artifacts all over
his office there from his different adventures
all across the timeline he even had an Iron Man
helmet in the background too just letting you
know that he'd actually faced a version of The
Avengers at some point in his timeline when Kang
grew tired of ruling over the past he set up the
mutant apocalypse as his successor in return to
the Future apocalypse later made a deal with the
celestials for their technology that's how
he got all of his armor his ship they kind
of did a version that during X-Men animated
series that's where his spaceship came from
why he has that in the distant past because
the celestials built it really apocalyptic
Scholars referred to and I quote a mighty ship
designed by creatures from beyond the stars
the next time King returned he came to the present
day of the Avenger to try and defeat them this
time using the actual King the Conqueror name in
wearing that same armor for the first time and
throughout his timeline he loosed some Against
The Avengers win some coming back in different
points in his timeline using different names with
different upgrades different identities he became
the Scarlet Centurion there was a child version
of Kang who became Iron lad on the Young Avengers
then kidamortis when that kid Kang tried to become
a good person the adult version of amortis Kang
was something they did during the Loki series he
remains King was a combination of the immortus
version of Kang and he who remains from the comics
who was a completely different character amortis
was meant to be Kang at the end of his timeline
who'd softened a little become more of a good
character as opposed to the king the Conqueror
version that we see in the trailer who's just
a full-blown Avengers villain the whole idea with
this Kang in the MCU is that he winds up capturing
Cassie Lane to force Ant-Man to help him steal
a device back that was stolen by Janet Van Dyne
when she escaped that will help him complete his
time ship so that he can go on winning the Kang
Multiverse War apparently the reason why he was
stuck in the quantum realm in the first place is
because Janet van dyne she discovered him when she
got stuck there initially he lied about who he was
what he was doing there in order to survive while
she was there she created her own Fortress in the
quantum realm and I believe that's what this
place is here the wreckage of this place they
worked together for a Time King manipulating her
into helping him use the quantum realm to win the
Kang Multiverse war and when she discovered who he
really was and what his plans were she sabotaged
his time travel ship and that's the reason why
Kang needs their help he wants to force Janet Van
Dyne to reveal what she did with the missing piece
and have Scott help him retrieve it so that he can
go on winning the Kang Multiverse War it sounds
like a lot of that plot has something to do with
this giant device that looks like shangshi's
10 rings of power I just did a video on this
because this seemed just like a giant version of
shangshi's 10 rings so it does seem like Kang is
the person who built the 10 Rings that's where
the signal is trans many two in the shangshi
post credit scene it also seems like he built Miss
Marvel's Bengals too I think the idea is that when
Ant-Man is trying to destroy this device they're
saying that it's the key to Kang's master plan
to win the Kang Multiverse War how he plans on
beating all the other Kang variants in making his
own timeline Supreme the only thing they haven't
revealed in all the trailer footage all the
interviews is why Kang is doing all this like why
does he want to win the king Multiverse War one of
the really big differences between Kang and Thanos
is that Kang is as much at war with his other
variants as he is with the Avengers like he's at
war with himself metaphorically and literally in
a way that Thanos never was the whole idea is that
it's meant to be a Multiverse Saga Marvel phase 4
Phase 5 and phase six so he's trying to win the
Kane Multiverse War 2.0 because he who remains
won the first version of that and was preventing
2.0 from starting but once Sylvie killed him the
timeline rebooted and it allowed all the other
timelines to be freed in the other evil versions
of Kang to rise up if you think I'm bad wait till
you meet my variants this can King the Conqueror
just happens to be one of those worst variants
but not the only one that we'll see there will
be another version of Kang during Loki season 2.
I've already done a full Loki season 2 trailer
video like I said for all the footage they've
already released I'll put a link for that at the
end of this down in the description but the next
big Marvel series is actually secret Invasion and
that won't be super connected to Loki season 2 or
what Kang is doing just in general it's setting up
more of an earth-based Marvel Phase 5 story which
is a version of dark rain from the comics where
the Scrolls try to take over the world in secret
Invasion but the villains take credit for getting
rid of them and ride that Newfound popularity to
try and take over the world themselves I think
we're supposed to get the next secret Invasion
trailer during the Super Bowl or around that
time as soon as they release it of course I'll do
a video for it the secret Invasion episodes will
drop around April or May after the Mandalorian
season 3 episodes the other big reminder is that
the last of us episodes on HBO are starting this
weekend I will be doing videos for that be sure
to check them out it is amazing it is an s tier
video game adaptation click here for my Last of
Us Episode 1 review and click here for my full
Ant-Man and the Wasp quantumania trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!